[Music]
well this is a wild
question from mark because i would argue
that my entire life
has been that
you got your perspective
i just want to be happy don't you want
to be happy
[Music]
this is going to be kind of off the
rails because my opportunity to speak to
gary i'm going to ask things that i'm
personally curious about
so i kind of have this theory that kind
of life has these phases to it
and for me kind of phase one was up
until i was 30
where i really had no clue what i was
about i didn't know what my passion was
i didn't know really where i was going
and i was really lucky i had this kind
of mentor who kind of
grabbed me and said you know how old are
you i said well i was 29
and he goes oh okay he goes you don't
have far to go
he goes usually when you hit 30 all of a
sudden
everything becomes clear and god lo and
behold
he was right then all of a sudden i
could go oh i like what i'm doing i can
see a path from here
i have family now i have balance and it
set up this wonderful period of my life
so here's what i was going to bring up
is that
the second period for me started when i
turned 45.
uh the next third period really started
45
and 45 was the year
that i left netflix 45 was a little bit
after the netflix
ipo and it was this real boundary for me
because i so distinctly remember we were
i went to the ipo we were in new york we
were up in the merrill lynch trading
floor
and it was kind of anticlimactic you
know there was no bells to ring no
confetti just kind of the trading
started
but it was a significant milestone and i
remember leaving the building and i was
with my eight-year-old son logan
and we had a new york objective
because he grew up on california this
belongs to me
and i go i'm gonna take him to get uh
some
real new york pizza so we're in the cab
and we're heading down from the merrell
building
downtown to go to a original race or one
of like 80 of them now
but um i remember thinking i could kind
of do whatever i want now
and it was a really weird feeling
because you think you have all these
opportunities but instead
it's kind of throws you off balance so
since in so many ways you and i have had
these similar
trajectories and i kind of know we see
the world the same way we have these
same motivations in some ways
some of the same super power and i know
that you just
hit 45 yes and i'm wondering
do you feel that things are changing for
you
i do and i think things are always
changing and to your point i think
you know round numbers get people
thoughtful i think people think
differently around their zero and five
birthday
you know whether it's 20 or 25 30 35
right
um you know for me
i as a child
spent a lot of time hanging out with
grandparents
i've been thinking about this a lot
lately um
i was very gravitated towards
you know 70 80 year olds when i was 7
8 9 10. just it was just a thing i was
very close to my great grandfather when
we first immigrated to america
spent a lot of time with him you know at
the park
when i was three four but i remember it
i literally remember it more maybe i was
more four
four then we moved to jersey i remember
like
i just and then definitely from like
1982 to 1988
every time a grandparent would come and
visit
i just always felt this weird
association towards them and would
always ask them stories
history and so i've always felt
in a lot of ways that in hindsight as i
got older i was like oh i'm an old soul
i like wisdom like oh i was such a bad
student but history was something i was
always
really the only bees i had on my report
card on regular classes not named
jim were in history and
and even like my current passion in
discovering what i think is about to
play out with nfts
and the whole non-fungible token
blockchain a lot of it has to do with
psychology and history and ip and all
this stuff so
things are changing but not from a
wisdom standpoint you know
i i of course i be uh i'll give you i'll
give you something tangible
i've come to realize recently called
last two three years that
my greatest vulnerability as a leader
believe it or not because people are
confused by this because i'm so candace
on interviews and on stage but as an
operator
i so struggle with delivering bad news
believe it or not that i i've struggled
with candor and i've created this
term for myself kind candor i've come to
realize
that it's a vulnerability and i want to
be better and all of us evolve and we
want to be better and
kind candor is something that i've stood
up recently in my own mind and now even
within vayner x
my holding company i want people to be
able to do that because it leads to
entitlement and resentment if you're not
deploying candor um
but i think what's happening for me is
i've always in my mind
put a premium on 50 to 60 years old
i've always probably since i was about
19 or 20
started having these feelings that 50 to
60 was going to be the money shot
and so you know when you're 26 and
thinking about 50
to 60 you're like oh my god i have a
whole another life to live before i even
enter my quote on quote prime
but now i'm 45 and i'm like okay i'm i'm
about to go into this
thing that i've put on a pedestal a
thing that's been intuitive to me
and i'm excited about it i feel like i'm
gearing up and i feel experienced
to go along with the raw talent that i
was gifted with
and um you know i never lacked
confidence not because i was audacious
but because
my confidence came from my conviction of
appreciating the process over the
results
yeah that the plunging in just the uh
let's let's do something and let's see
what happens
and so um i'm pretty excited
about um do you still believe it's the
money shot
yeah i i you know i i do feel like it
makes sense to me and maybe when i'm 60
i'm like no wait a minute it was 70 days
you know like
you know but i i do think i do think
there's a time and a place and a prime
and a
i do think that you know i think i've
always felt that business
had more similarities to sport than
people realized
i think it's not you know i think it's
naive not to there's been no athlete
that's come along and has been
consistently the same athlete for all
eight 12 15 years of her or his career
there is a prime and uh yeah
i get it the thing that i'm trying to
curious and
you know i'll check in with you in five
years and see how it feels is that the
uh
certainly 10 is going to be more
interesting because i'll be in the eye
of the storm
if you check it with me in five years
which i'm happy to do i'm going to be
hyped because i'm like here we go
there probably is some some time in your
schedule just about freeing up
nine or ten years from now but you know
it's i do i spend as you do a ton of
time with
young people you know people are still
in high school people are still in
college and i'm
i'm you know i'm spending a bunch of
time with some tick tock people right
now who have this huge
early fame and it's funny because they
are
very economically focused i mean to them
that's the hurdle and it's you know what
you try to say
and i never quite know how it's getting
through that
you'll see that there needs to be more
to it
than that and that what i think of huge
advantage of when we hit
45 and when i hit 45 is you do have all
these skills
and you go i know i can do business
stuff but now i've got to be selective
about
what i want to apply these skills to
what is the business that i want to do
what is the non-business that i want to
do how do i want to use it
it's a really kind of interesting
interesting
struggle at least for me of saying hi i
think i think
when you're young time is your teammate
yes exactly and i think as you get older
you you know it's really how the brain
works when you're
seven and you've got to wait to your
10th birthday you've only been on earth
for seven years
it's half your life ahead of like half
the life you lived is what you're
anticipating to be double digits
but when you get to 45 and one year is a
small percent like it goes fast right
that's how
you get and so i think that's an
extremely valid point one of the things
i worry about
is i live in such abundance
that i need to be thoughtful about my
time resource
yeah and i do feel like i'm vulnerable
to that mistake and it is something that
runs subconsciously and has now become
conscious
for me of like hey you value the
serendipity and the learning
and the curiosity so much you need to be
careful here because
how many more innings do you have plenty
because i'm a guy that's like i'm going
for another 45
but but you still need to be thoughtful
and you never know when the rock hits
you in the head and it's over and so you
got to be thoughtful
but it's also i think that you know i
think one of the things that you and i
have in common is also a huge curse is
that we
we see these huge opportunities i mean i
know that that's how you're wired it's
that almost
life arbitrage thing and whether it's
being at a garage sale and seeing
something i'll go oh my god i can buy
that for five bucks and sell it for 20.
but i see that all the time not at
garage sales but i see that in business
opportunities like
just like you know with with empathy
where you go oh my gosh there is this
opening for a native
and you go [ __ ] i'm just going to create
it yeah but the thing is
those especially as you get better and
get more attuned and get better skills
those things accelerate and that's when
you go holy [ __ ] i've got to back up a
little bit
i've got to realize i've got to focus a
little bit and kind of pick my battles
i literally texted my brother aj today
four hours ago three hours ago
crippled by opportunity
it's it's tricky it really is tricky and
it's so
hard i mean and i feel it and i
personally feel
in all kinds of ways i certainly feel it
like you know i'm so lucky now i get all
kinds of
invitations either to invest or to
advise or to be part of things
and man it is such a struggle to say no
i just it's not because especially when
you're an optimist and an entrepreneur
yes you're in the yes business
i i once i once described it to someone
as it's like someone
it's like walking by on the sidewalk and
seeing a little basket full of puppies
with no one there and god you can't walk
by you've got
someone's got to do this and whenever i
see an opportunity i go i just want to
do it and i want to make it real no
matter how unrealistically uh
impossible it is it's just a really it's
a really tricky
fun i mean i'm certainly glad i was
gifted with that it certainly has
worked out really well for me but boy
sometimes i've really got a struggle to
uh
to control myself yep
um i got a related uh or somewhat
related one so since we brought up
empathy so
probably you the same one of the things
i get asked all the time by
entrepreneurs is when do i stop
how do i know when to give up and
i'll save time i never know forget how
to answer that
but the question is possibly difficult
question
the the answer is nobody on earth knows
so i you know i did a company after
after netflix which was looker data
which we tried to sell
and i look back um it's such a 2020
hindsight thing
and you did it because of this
information you have at the time and you
look back and go ah
we should have wrote it we were on the
verge of going public just think what
that would have been like not just as a
business but as a cultural thing
and i'm wondering would you struggle
with the same thing with empathy or even
before that with uh
rezzy you know empathy and rezzy were
great exits
they're nine figure type deals they were
big wins i had partners who were
operating
i was more in chairman and founder level
so i've never really sold a company that
i'm navigating day to day
they're both family businesses vayner
and
wine library and so i didn't have
any regrets with either because i wasn't
the jockey
i was the inventor of the horse or a
co-inventor
but i wasn't the jockey you know i might
have been the trainer
but i wasn't the jockey and so i don't
have those
feelings because of that
scenario and for everybody who's
listening back to trying to provide
value
you know heaven heaven
my dream of heaven is i'll show you all
the scenarios
because i think that'd be really cool
but but other than that
might make pretend of how i want heaven
to be nobody can ever tell you that if
you
held on to it for another month that x
would have happened
and there's a and that's cool and then
there's a million people who
wrote it out for another three years and
got gotta i mean you know you and i have
run in
circles where we know incredible horror
stories of people passing on selling
their company for 210 million
only to have it go out of business or
pass and selling it for 44 million
only to have it sold for 19. like people
always
think of it as a one-way street it goes
both ways
and that's important oh it certainly is
especially if you've been
certainly like i have in silicon valley
for a long time you've seen so many
horror stories it gets drilled into you
that you don't want to bet your whole
life on an uncertain future i mean
there's one thing to have
confidence there's one thing to take
risks but certainly even the biggest
risk takers do what they can
to hedge the risks one time
i was um i worked for a company called
borland a big software company a long
time ago
was crushing it because we were looking
like we were going to overtake microsoft
if you can imagine how ridiculous an
assumption was that
back then but i but i had stock options
and they were worth a lot of money and i
was
in a bar in hong kong with our vp of
sales on some sales tour
just to put a crazy scenario here and
i was going god this stock price it is
going great
and he goes yeah i hope you're selling
and i go selling why would i want to
sell it's like
it's going up and up and up and he goes
no you are out of your mind he goes
you you should every time your stock
vests sell
and he goes you'll always have more
coming
than you sold and if you're doing a
great job they'll keep giving you more
but if you don't sell anything your ups
your downside is unlimited you could go
to zero all you're doing is taking
slight
caps on your upside and then from that
moment
that was a long time ago
every single chance i get i try and
hedge i mean even with looker as that
was going up
every chance every round we'd sell into
the round a little bit
just to take a little bit of money off
the table and go i have no idea what's
going to happen but at least i have
i have something for my efforts it's a
there's the other side of it
i was early into facebook but not as
early as the original 102
employees a lot of those kids sold
facebook at 18 and 19 when it hit the
floor at 25 to 27.
you know that was a mistake you know
they were saying you know some of those
people were thrilled to get the 10
million dollars the problem is
10 times that is a hundred and so you
know
there's a lot of ways to play it yeah i
think you know
i think the real key is you can't you
just can't look back you can't worry
about this stuff it's unknowable
you just got to move on and you go
there'll be more uh be more fun yet to
come
and i think the thing is if you're tr
the same people who are always worried
about what could have been and i don't
want to do this i make the wrong
decision to the people who are scared to
move forward
who are scared to you know another great
thing that you and i kind of have in
common is this whole
most advancement comes from just
starting just doing
something stop stop thinking i love the
uh
you know you i don't know how many how
long ago this was you did that what
seven or eight hundred page slide deck
about
how to do sixty some odd pieces of
social media in a day
yep and i remember that was it was one
line in there or something that goes the
thing that gets
everyone in trouble is they have this
standard
of production value correct and so they
just spend the whole time
tweaking fonts and rather than just
[ __ ] putting it out there and then
moving on to the next one
and that's so much more powerful and god
that's something that i've done
time and time and time again is train
myself that i'm totally okay with [ __ ]
i'm totally okay testing something that
has broken links and has
bad images you learn
nothing from something perfect that
never seems like
you know i always say you can't read
about doing push-ups
i have a similar one i go you can't
learn to play tennis by watching a video
that's it that's exactly right
yeah you gotta y'all listen while we're
sharing the other one is that basically
uh
the key to success is being willing to
seem like you're a five-year-old
which is it's funny you say that i've
been really i'm writing a new book and
that will be out probably in the winter
and curiosity is a very big theme in it
yeah i really believe that that has
helped me quite a bit
with curiosity it's not knowing in
advance what can't be done
and it's being willing to look like an
idiot you know i don't know if you know
anybody
humans speak any languages you got to
sound like you're five years old for a
couple years and being willing to go
into restaurants and say
i can't speak i'm going to try
and that's how i'm going to learn
humility humility
it's a it's a it's a big one too it's uh
it's funny
i'm very hot on those keep going no it's
cool
i mean i i want to as you as you
probably know i just i'm trying to
follow in the garyvee
path i have a podcast just when you're
going
i'm not going to interview for the
podcast but i'm going to do a trying to
of
a podcast and mostly not one where i
interview
you know really successful entrepreneurs
because that's been done and done
way better than i could do it but kind
of doing much more along the askgaryvee
stuff where i work with and mentor
people which i've been doing for 15
years and now i'm just recording it
but it's called that'll never work and
one of the things i was curious about
one of my premises is that
every single person who does something
new hears that
you all come rushing in and tell your
wife that'll never work you tell your
investors that'll never work
and i'm just i'm sure you've heard that
100 times
and i wonder if there's some of those
that really stand out in your mind when
someone told you that'll never work and
what you were thinking at the time
well this is a wild question from mark
because
i would argue that my entire life
has been that
i mean my you know i
pre i've been innovating my whole career
you know
i was a bad student so i from day one
i was told i would never be anything by
the establishment outside of my mom
you know so that was good because it
made me not scared
right you know like by the time i became
a grown-up
you know i was told but the one place i
was never told that was at the consumer
level
at the lemonade stand at the baseball
card show
and my dad's liquor store i was shining
the consumer always said yes to me but
humans
who had judgment of what i was up to
always said no i'm going through it
right now
last two weeks i've been explaining to
everybody what i'm going to do in nfts
now i have some reputation so people are
a little bit more
thoughtful with their nose they
they hedge their bets but i mean my dad
was told by every lik
all these uncles of mine other liquor
store owners that i grew up knowing
they all told my dad he was crazy for
letting me build a website
the internet was a fad 1996.
it's a fad how could you spend 25 000
15 on the site and then a little to kick
it up and that was a lot of money for a
small business that does 300
000 in profit a year and you know
building winelibrary.com was crazy
moving all the money from
print and direct mail to google adwords
was crazy
now i built this 40 million dollar
company from four
and now i'm spending all my time in this
thing called youtube and making videos
who do i think i am what is this that's
crazy
then my financial advisor said it was
crazy that i put all my money that i'd
saved into facebook and twitter stock
that was crazy starting an advertising
agency
by being a wine merchant that was crazy
you know buying bitcoin in 2014 was
crazy
this you know i mean
i mean nothing nothing i don't really
remember
anything i was excited about that wasn't
met with
blind you can do it from my mom and then
probably not from everybody else that's
the story of my life
i i've kind of learned that my wife is
almost a reverse indicator
that she goes uh what i go
i am on to something yeah it's true i
mean gosh
every it it's such a huge piece of
knowledge for anyone to gather which is
that no one else knows anything
that the they're all just kind of using
these patterns they've learned from
other things and trying to handicap
whether something new
is actually going to work or not and so
it's so much easier to go that'll never
work because they're probably going to
be right more times than not but it's
just such a terribly
um piece of advice it's happening to me
right now as i
explained to people that nft is going to
be
the ultimate arbitrage for influencers
that build real
communities the the way that artists are
going to get their
their actual economics the fact that
people
will care about social currency at scale
virtual goods
you know these are all things that i
believe in and it's hard for people to
understand
i have to say things to them like how
much do you think three years ago at the
height of it
two years ago at the height of it
somebody would pay for a blue check on
instagram
and you know the way however i storytell
that a lot of people are like oh a lot
i'm like well that's what nft is going
to be they're like but wait a minute i
can take
a screenshot of it i'm like you can also
have a fake prada bag
you're allowed to buy a fake rolex you
know
people struggle with new things they
don't understand the blockchain they
don't understand you know these things
and so
i mean this is why i love having a
relationship with you i used to go
crazy with people about netflix versus
blockbuster
right me too yes but you had a lot more
financial and emotional reasons too i
saw it from a hundred [ __ ] miles away
it just was obvious to me
and listen and not to be not to be
kissing your ass here but
seriously i was a wine person a long
time ago and
i was a direct marketing guy and when i
saw
what you were doing i was going oh jesus
this is
i can't believe he's the first person
who's kind of building this out
it's so evident to me and not just and
same with jeff bezos i'll go
they're not nuts this is so evident i
don't know if you're going to see this
you're about to see some goose i
literally literally
there have been three companies that
i've ever bought public stock of
ever in my entire life over the counters
it's just i'm you know what's funny
about me i don't want the money i want
the happiness
i don't get great joy in buying stock
one of the reasons i love nft
is i love to doodle and yeah people
don't know this about me
so like this speaks to me i've always
been obsessed with walt disney and vince
mcmahon why
ip creation the macho man and hulk hogan
are goofy and mickey mouse i get it and
so this is gonna be a great space stream
but
the reason you just said bezos and i got
goosebumps is amazon netflix and shopify
are the three companies
that i've bought every other public
share i own is because i
invested in a lot of private companies
that went public
right i have a big one with coinbase i'm
gonna have those shares but it's not
because i'm buying them on the open
market and by the way i probably should
because i've been very right about a lot
of companies
and i've just it's just not where i get
my excitement but
i get it it's very obvious to me yeah
it's such a it's such a great
a great thing but it is it makes it
makes what it what makes less exciting
it makes it fun it's being able to see
these things happening and go
here's what i think is going to go down
and having it go down doesn't get much
better than that
so gary by the way the historical rep
the historical correctness
is what i live for is what you what it's
what i live for
oh i know i like it i like it it's a fun
game
are you better at seeing it
than others it's a real business
challenge for thought leaders and
thinkers and pontificators and debaters
and curiosities
like that's my game yeah and i think in
this game that we play so much of it
comes down to this
i'll call it informed instinct which is
that you go there's all this stuff in my
head and i
can't draw the dots for you i can't
necessarily lay it all logically but
it's lining up
and something is telling me it's going
to go this way and then people go oh
he's a good guesser or he's got
and it is but it's also trusting this
impulse that something's going to happen
is actually going to happen
that once you learn to trust yourself on
that it's such a great uh
way to sort out all these possible
things you could be doing
right well cool listen like i know i
gotta lose you in a second to stay and
keep you on your schedule
um one really last question you are
have so much [ __ ] going on and i hear
you hear you say the balance is so
important do you have any certain trick
you use to try and keep your
head from exploding from making sure you
have uh have time for the other stuff
not judgment not what not judging myself
yeah that's a good one a lack of
judgment on yourself allows you to not
judge others which is healthy
and it also makes you not dwell which
allows you to drop
33 plates while you've got 86 in the air
and you're still thrilled with your net
positive outcome
in that looking back in historical
correctness people only remember that
one plate you manage to
keep going and they forget about the
other uh 79 that uh
one thousand percent and if you should
and if you have the humility to respect
your craft
i love entrepreneurship not because it's
money but because it's fair
yeah when i lose i deserve it and i like
it
you know like i i like that i passed on
uber twice i like that i bought some
bitcoin in 14 but not enough i like my
losses
yeah there's some of the plates you drop
and that's fine you know it's part of
the nature of it
closest to a meritocracy we're gonna
find yes that's true
well cool listen thanks so much for
squeezing half an hour with me um
good luck and hopefully we can get a
chance to see each other face to face in
the not too uh
distant future talk to you soon all
right see you gary bye-bye
youtube watcher what's up it's garyvee
first of all thank you so much i hope
you're doing super well during these
times i also want to ask you please
subscribe because my
commitment and exploration of youtube is
about to explode stories polls
more content more engagement more
surprise and delight
this is the time to subscribe i hope you
consider it and i hope i see you soon